so nice to meet you guys and so nice to
meet a fellow Maggie that very rarely
ever happens to me great name lovely to
meet you I'm really mad
yeah I was excited to see that it was a
that you play a Maggie who who uh owns a
record store because sitting just off
camera here I have a very large
collection of vinyl records so I was
like oh she's just playing me then
really I love hearing this oh it's
amazing but you both obviously uh were
in the show in the first season you
played quite small roles now you've come
back in a much bigger capacity so you
know what was that like getting to be a
bigger part of the story yeah just
really extraordinary and absolutely
wonderful
um Neil emailed both of us separately in
the in lockdown actually a time when
honestly nothing was happening it seemed
and I couldn't imagine a time when we'd
be able to have a cruise together and a
whole bunch of actors together so the
fact that he had that in his mind that
he was going to be spending his time
writing season two
writing apart for for me calling her the
best name ever Maggie
um it was debating it was just a gift in
itself and then so kind of the fact that
we even got to make it in itself is
extraordinary
um but I think we've really made these
six episodes that are completely
beautiful actually
um and the stories that we get to tell
in the adventures we get to go on is is
yeah just wonderful yeah I didn't have
seen that coming couldn't see that
coming and as just as actresses you're
you spend a certain amount of time on a
on a show and although playing the then
Bonanza was just brilliant because we
were also fans of the books so we knew
the kind of
um influence that they had in in the
plot
um we were there for a quite a
relatively small amount of time and in
this version of of the world we uh
yeah so we've got this whole journey
through which is which is really nice
because we set the tone in the first one
the the whole tone of the show and that
carries on in this one but we're
different characters which is great yeah
yeah and and you you mentioned that you
got an email from Neil Gaiman about this
but you know how do you how do you react
when Neil Gaiman of all people you know
emails you and says I'm going to put you
in the second season of the show and
it's going to be a character
specifically tailored to you and named
after you does that that must be insane
right yes yeah I I immediately cried
um what what was what was yours it's two
o'clock in the morning because uh I've
done some time difference was occurring
so I was a little bit like well that's
clearly somebody else oh it had some
weird joke going on and um but I mean
even the first time around was just as
mad yeah so
um it's it would I think it's because we
were fans already I think you'd probably
would probably react the same way you
would if you were a fan asked to do the
same thing and you you obviously then
you you you cry or think it's not you
and then you immediately say but yes
please and then you have to get
professional and yes yes yeah yeah I
mean it's just it's one of my most
favorite gifts I've ever been given did
get it all confusing on set you know
being named the same thing as your
character because I can imagine because
I never hear the name Maggie I would
just be going yes yes to everything yep
that's the thing you don't hear your
name said that often and especially when
you're an actor you're referred to as
the character's name so there you first
of all your names being banded around
and then and then people would get us
mixed up yeah they would even though we
had our own names yeah and all we'd be
we just become Maggie and Nina like it
was one word which I quite liked you
know it works it's fine could be a
double actor who is the world yeah yeah
and you two get quite a quite a fun
subplot because you do get to be the
characters that azira fell and Crowley
are kind of trying to Four Weddings and
a funeral a bit like you're in your own
little own little rom-com so I was
curious do you guys have favorite ROM
comes I know Nina you were in Love
Actually which is one of my personal
favorites but yeah there we are there
you go
um When Harry Met Sally Is that's a
rom-com right I mean it's just perfect
to me it's sort of it's kind of oh I
just love it so much it's it is my
absolute favorite of all time I really
like The Wedding Singer do you yeah it
starts and I start crying I don't know
why I don't know why I love that well I
did actually watch Notting Hill the
other days when I've sort of forgotten
how completely brilliant that is too I
really enjoyed it very good Trish it's
very good choice
Nina I know you also worked with Michael
Sheen and David Tennant on stage I
assume sort of between seasons of this
show so working with them on that and
working with them on this how different
is that well when we first started when
we first did stage that was right in
lockdown so that was no one met anyone
we were all on Zoom I'd actually work
with both of them before in real life so
I knew what they looked like in 3D and
then
um and then yeah and it's been three
three series since but each one has sort
of grown out of just zoom uh so so that
was nice
um
they're pretty they're pretty similar to
have you see them we see what you get
with them they're very very cool dudes I
have one final question for you too and
that is the fact that the one of the
most iconic parts of good Omens is
Crowley's Bentley which is cursed to
play Nothing But Queen songs forever and
ever and ever so I'm curious what your
favorite Queen song is oh
I mean I love the stuff now and I love
um Killer Queen and uh and I also love
um those were the days
that was makes me yeah yeah we we the
there's still some really beautiful
little Queen
um Snippets quite cleverly used in
season two yeah be on the watch for that
it's really clever awesome well thank
you so much for talking to me today I'm
so excited to meet another Maggie thank
you so much